genau mein Thema beschäftigt sich heute
Abend mit einem Problem dass wir trotz
Ukraine und corona-krise und so weiter
nicht aus den Augen verlieren dürfen
weil es uns alle betrifft und vor allem
auch unsere junge Generation und zwar
geht es darum dass der demografische
Wandel den wir ja bei der täglich
erleben dafür sorgen wird dass wir auf
einen dramatischen Fachkräftemangel
hinlaufen werden und die Politik schaut
dabei zu das ist schlecht in 2025 werden
auch die Geburten starken Jahrgänge
langsam aber sicher in den Ruhestand
gehen der digitale Wandel in der
Arbeitswelt tut hier sein übriges so
schon heute ist es so dass mehr als zwei
Millionen Stellen unbesetzt sind schon
heute ist es so dass mehr als die Hälfte
aller Unternehmen angibt dass sie ihre
Stellen zumindestens vorübergehend nicht
besetzen kann so und das betrifft nicht
nur industriehandwerk und IT man
vielleicht denken könnte mitnichten es
geht hier vor allem auch um ungelernte
im Dienstleistungsbereich gehen Sie hier
in Berlin mal abends aus oder tagsüber
auch was sehen wir in Restaurants
Ruhetage werden eingeführt aufgrund des
Personalmangels oder eben stark
verkürzte Öffnungszeiten ich denke aber
auch in unsere Flughäfen ja die mit der
Abwicklung gar nicht mehr
hinterherkommen und wenn man über
sicherheits- und reinigungswirtschaft
spricht die Zahlen sind noch
alarmierender hier sprechen 80% der
Unternehmen davon dass sie nicht mehr
besetzen können was besetzt werden muss
also krasse arbeitsagen ich persönlich
finde dass das Zahlen sind die uns alle
alarmieren sollten weil die nicht nur
die Unternehmen selber und der
Mittelstand betroffen sind nicht nur für
die wird es teuer sondern unterm Strich
für uns alle vor allem auch für den
Steuerzahler und deswegen wünsche ich
mir von der Politik dass Sie hier eine
Bremse einlegt dass sie diese
Entwicklung wirklich mal hier ein Vlog
rein rammt und endlich mal Maßnahmen
ergreift die dafür sorgen dass wir auf
einen grünen Zweig wiederkommen denn ich
finde das ist vor allem eine Frage der
Generationengerechtigkeit Frau Borsbach
ist die Politik denn im politischen
Berlin überhaupt alarmiert genug ich war
hier letztens um 13 Uhr um die Ecke beim
Bäcker ja auf Dinge der hat auch
eigentlich immer so bis 19 Uhr auf um
13:30 Uhr wurde die Tür zugemacht für
mich gab es dann auch nichts mehr weil
genau wie sie beschrieben haben es gab
keine Verkäufer und deswegen musste
geschlossen werden an dem Tag ist denn
da in der Politik genug
Alarmbereitschaft da ja ganz
offensichtlich ja nicht ich kann das
jetzt nicht bestätigen ich kann nur
sagen dass mich sehr sehr viel
verwundert was eigentlich offensichtlich
ist weil wir es ja im Alltag immer
wieder erleben so und jetzt würde man ja
meinen dass man darüber spricht dann
über Lösungsansätze ernsthaft diskutiert
für mich wäre das sowas wie eine Frage
wie kann man den arbeitsstandort
Deutschland wieder attraktiv bekommen
jedes Jahr das muss man sich auch mal
klar machen gehen rund 50.000 junge gut
ausgebildete Menschen zwischen 20 und 33
verlassen dieses Land nicht weil sie es
hier nicht Lebens- und liebenswert
finden ganz im Gegenteil sondern weil
das Arbeiten für Sie hier schlicht
unattraktiv ist mir fällt es auch
persönlich schwer im jungen Menschen zu
erklären warum er ausgerechnet in dem
Land arbeiten und Geld verdienen soll
was von allen Industrieländern die mit
Abstand Steuer und Abgabenlast hat das
ist einfach nicht schön überlegt mal wir
sind hier bei der was Abgaben angeht
kratzen wir in der 40% Marke für
Kinderlose so das hat der
wissenschaftliche Beirat des
Bundeswirtschaftsministeriums
ausgerechnet dass das auf 54% ansteigen
wird und ich finde persönlich dass das
auch grob ungerecht ist zu Lasten
unserer jungen und erwerbsfähigen
Generation und zum Stichwort
Alarmbereitschaft aber wir haben gerade
das Bürgergeld das haben wir jetzt
diskutiert in den letzten Wochen das ist
das genaue Gegenteil von dem was
eigentlich erreicht werden sollte wir
sollten in diesen Zeiten Menschen
motivieren arbeiten zu gehen ja wir
sollten ihn eigentlich den Weg dafür
ebnen und sie nicht
demotivieren so wie es passiert ist lass
mich daran stört ja dass die Kissen der
sozialen Hängematte gerade weiter
aufgeschüttelt werden statt dafür zu
sagen dass man dass man die Anreize
schafft die geschaffen werden müssen was
ist diese angebliche Reform die da
losgetreten wird
das fördert ja quasi die
Erwerbslosigkeit wenn ich das mal so auf
den Punkt bringen darf es Marc hat
klingen es ist aber so kein Weg zum
Abend keine Rückruf auf Ersparnisse noch
nicht mal neuen Job muss man einem
Arbeitnehmer dann zumuten also das stört
mich eigentlich alles dran Herr Hoffmann
merken sie auch schon den
Fachkräftemangel in Ihrer Klinik wie das
mein Name aber auf jeden Fall genau also
genau ich habe vor einigen Tagen noch
zum Kollegen gesagt ich kann dieses Wort
nicht mehr hören weil wir uns täglich
damit beschäftigen also Deutschland
haben wir wir haben ich spreche auch mit
Kollegen wir haben viele Kliniken die
nicht mehr wissen wie sie ihre
patientenversorgen sollen wir haben das
Problem teilweise auch das wir einfach
zu wenig Leute haben für die Betten die
Betten können ausgelastet sein aber
können nicht bespielt werden primär
jetzt mit mit
nichtärztlichen Personal nicht spreche
zum Pflegepersonal auch da überlegen wir
seit Jahren wie wir den Job attraktiver
machen können Anreize gab es vielleicht
finanzielle Art wir kennen das Klatschen
in der corona-pandemie aber vielleicht
vermutlich wenig gebracht richtig viele
viele
Dingern fühlen sich davon eigentlich ja
hinters Licht geführt das bringt den gar
nicht der Job ist zumal also wenn ich
für meinen Bereich spreche der Job ist
für viele nicht attraktiv genug und wir
versuchen Pflegekräfte aus dem Autos
Ausland zu gewinnen ich hatte heute noch
Kollegen aus England damit den ich mich
besprochen habe zu diesem Thema die
haben dasselbe Probleme im Manager ist
ich frage mich mal was können wir tun
was wir tun können es sind Job
attraktiver machen das bedeutet aber
auch dass wir also im Krankenhaus
beispielsweise viel mehr ins Gespräch
gehen ein Teil meines Jobs bestimmt zehn
Prozent besteht darin einfach zuzuhören
mit den Kollegen zu sprechen vom
Pflegebereich und zu hören was das
Problem ist unbefristete Verträge das
ist ja auch 5 Minuten
ist das anders aber für für Ärzte und
Pflegende gibt es gibt ja es gibt ja
begrüßungsgelder sogar es gibt ja
Prämien wenn jemand kommt und ich glaube
was für die meisten wichtig ist ist
nicht unbedingt die Bezahlung die immer
besser wird und was für uns generell was
im Fachkräftemangel angeht und das
hatten sie glaube ich nicht erwähnt ist
auch das immer mehr Menschen Teilzeit
arbeiten wollen also es gibt immer
weniger die vollzeitarbeiten bei meinen
Assistenzärzten beispielsweise
machen wir das natürlich möglich aber
ist natürlich schwieriger wenn wenn man
keine weniger Kontinuität hat oder wenn
wenn andere Oberärzte beispielsweise
auch da mag ich konservativ sein aber
wenn sie auch ein 75 prozentstelle haben
was funktioniert bei uns aber wenn das
jeder wollte dann hätten wir wieder ein
Loch also bei ihnen haben wir jetzt
einmal gehört dass bei ihnen
unbefristete Verträge sind das ist schon
mal positiv aber hier würde ich gerne
noch einmal zu Frau Borsbach gehen weil
das ist ja nicht überall so die meisten
jungen Leute kriegen ja befristete
Verträge und eine andere
Anspruchshaltung die ich immer für mich
identifiziere ist dieses Studium über
alles kann uns das auch zum Problem
werden das eigentlich nicht mehr im
Schulsystem geworden auf die
individuellen Bedürfnisse eingegangen
wird ich glaube das ist schon längst zum
Verhängnis geworden ich habe diesen ich
diesen akademisierungswagen ich habe
selber auch studiert aber nie
nachvollziehen können also weil wir
brauchen alles nein das ist wirklich so
muss man mal so hart sagen und wir haben
einfach wir müssen uns überlegen wie
kann kann man auch Ausbildung wieder
attraktiv gestalten weil sie ist es ja
eigentlich wo jetzt hier nicht ins
Detail gehen aber wenn man sich mal
Schwestern ist auch eine Ausbildung
gemacht ist ja nicht nur Akademisierung
bei Ihnen zu Hause sowieso nicht also
von unseren Schwestern wenn ich die
einzige die die studiert hat tatsächlich
und dass das muss auch nicht sein und
müssen aber schon und uns da auch er
oder die Politik ist ja auch ehrlich
machen sich überlegen wie kommt das und
wie können wir da auch ein bisschen
unterstützen beispielsweise das Handwerk
ja das soll heutzutage läuft das ja ganz
ganz skurril ab ja da können sich die er
sagt ja Azubi ja dann irgendwann zu
deinem potenziellen Arbeitgeber nach
Bewerbungsgespräch sie sind jetzt unter
meiner Top 3 ich meine das sind ja
wirklich Situationen ist es bei ihnen
genauso ja und ganz kurz noch mal zum
Thema hier Vollzeit Teilzeit und so
weiter natürlich gibt es viele gerade
hier in Berlin die Diskussion auch jeden
Tag irgendwie sagen ich möchte weniger
arbeiten ich werde TagesWoche und so
weiter es gibt aber auch den Fall der
andersrum ist auch gerade bei uns Frauen
und sagt also gerade bei meinem Alter
jetzt so 30er 40er die möchten gerne
Vollzeit arbeiten sie können es aber
nicht Stichwort Kinderbetreuung also wo
ich auch sage das ist auch ein
bekommen und das ist auch Potenzial was
brach liegt gerade bei guten jungen
Frauen das kann eigentlich nicht sein
genauso wie bei älteren Menschen auch
dass man einfach mal sagt und offen
darüber spricht hier müssen das einfach
auch koppeln ja Lebenserwartung und
Arbeitszeit und das sind einfach Themen
die mir gerade auch in der aktuellen
Politik gerade unter so einer Ampel
massifehlen das sind immer sehr im
krisenmodus und Schluss weil wir sind
zum Ende der Sendung hingekommen selten
hatten wir so wenig Zeit gefühlt wie
heute schönen Abend noch wir sehen uns
nächste Woche Dienstag